[Musique]
jamais compris j'adorais à je trouve ça
fou maintenant je vais y réfléchir mais
je comprendrais jamais salue aujourd'hui
je suis avec safia je m'appelle safia
j'ai une chaîne qui s'appelle sa fille à
vendôme
ça fait maintenant cinq ans que j'y sur
youtube ce que je fais c'est surtout des
blogs mais tu sais de ce genre de blog
où tu peux passer des infos un peu sympa
j'invite à voir cela et oui tout de
suite d'un coup du blog à barcelone
c'est pas pareil que dublin a paris je
me suis dit ça fait très longtemps que
j'ai pas mentaliser quelqu'un sur la
chaîne et vous me l'avez souvent dit
dans les commentaires donc aujourd'hui
oui d'abord te faire choisir pour le
coup hasard un concept
alors j'écris plein de concept ici en
même temps que je vous parle vous devez
voir les vidéos de la vidéo de quand
j'ai réalisé ce petit carnet et c'est
que des concepts avec un symbole tu vas
parler de la terre et que la terre un
objectif
l'objectif avec la cible je vous en fais
passer comme ça vous voyez ça la nage et
or si vous voulez voir ma qualité de
dessinateur
j'ouvre une chaîne secondaire fabien ne
s'est pas décidé et tu lèves tu referme
c'est bon ok maintenant on est parti on
parle si tel concept est le symbole en
tête à huy formidable le but c'est qu'on
voit ce qu'on peut faire par rapport aux
symboles qu'elle a choisi
est ce que je pressens qu'elle a choisi
[Musique]
alary en tout cas on arrivait dans le
20e devant un resto que j'aime bien qui
s'appelle les ours
[ __ ] la meuf comment elles me parlent
qu'ils appellent les ours et il ya
beaucoup de real
dessiné par leur fin de tournage on va
la pause et à l'accueil des aînés stats
j'ai filmé tu vas voir cette décision à
prendre sur ce parcours cette décision à
prendre
tout le long de ce trajet on va marcher
à chaque intersection tu devra prendre
une décision ça marche je t'expliquerai
comment on fera la décision c'est pas
toi réellement qui va la prendre c'est
aussi le hasard
donc j'ai pris des parts qui symbolisait
le plus de le hasard savoir d'aidé et je
suis on va pas jouer aux dés dans la wii
s'est montré qu'on paye et du coup j'ai
pris un jeu de cartes
c'était moins compliqué alors là on a
une intersection le choisissent la
direction bah voyons mais on va le faire
au hasard on va utiliser la même
procédure à chaque fois là il y aura
soit tout droit soit à gauche soit à
droite en vigueur dans ma poche rien là
bluff mais il est où dans ma poche
incroyable jamais je n'aurais jamais
pensé à ça mais on peut s'arrêter là ok
on est au top premier choix premier
choix alors regarde ce qui va se passer
tu vas prendre le jeu que tu va mélanger
si je les prix oui des douceurs fils son
jeu meredith et la poche
jacques carrier pas complètement veux
pas tu le mélange non non non on s'en
fiche
en fait j'ai cherché comment on pouvait
avoir quand est ce qu'on aura trois
possibilités au maximum on reviendra
jamais sur nos pas et donc j'ai trouvé à
chaque fois c'est son amour je te le dis
pas avant pour pat influence et mélanger
si tu mets le doigt sur une carte celle
que tu veux toi
celle ci tu la sors du jeu tu la
regardes pas pour l'instant tu la plaque
contre toi si la carte est rouge c'est à
gauche
en fait c'est dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre dans ma tête cissé rouge
c'est à gauche 6 et noir c'est tout
droit dit ces vallées d'amour waes état
doit donc rouge à gauche noir tout droit
figure à droite et tu t es tu as quoi
comme car si green à l'infini windham
donc on va à droite
exactement et ce sera à chaque fois le
même processus exactement
donc première intersection première
intersection nous partons maintenant sur
notre droite en fait voulait fermer les
routes pour toi il a mérité donc là tout
droit on peut y aller aussi loin du
droit à droite ou à gauche
où est ce qu'on va se faire le petit
tirage au sort celle qui va partir parce
que tellement drôle ça ferait un super
flanc
rouge gauche
rouge gauche noir tout droit
je suis là pour toi tu vois qu'à la base
je l'avais fait deux propositions soit
une vidéo je mentalise comme ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas fait ça me
bottai bien soit un truc genre serait
mémoire et tous les sétois cas d'ira
j'aimerais bien tout le monde à nice sur
le thème des choix j'aime bien
et oui c'est bien moi j'aime bien
comprendre et là c'est un truc qui me va
je sais qu'il ya toujours une
explication rationnelle
j'aime bien comprendre le sais pas si je
ferai une explication de cette vidéo je
sais pas dites nous dans les
commentaires si vraiment vous voulez des
pistes mais moi là bas je pensais faire
cette vidéo un peu comme on faisait
l'année dernière c'est à dire de temps
en temps ben je vous dis pas et vous
avez vos propres théories et c'est
rigolo ça me fait rire d'ailleurs
d'élire les portes
ah bah oui oui on va le faire comme ça
secoue les mois le trépied jusqu'à ce
que l'on puisse plus que les 401 4000
abonnés centre lourd soit
on en a rien entre temps chaque année si
ça marche peinture nains 2
bon alors gauche là bas tout
et alors
il bondit
goss
pourrait faire hésiter pas rien
bush
très bien roulé ce sont nos badges pour
cette pas du tout qu'on serait là c'est
pas une chasse au trésor alors
mais sinon risque pas de le trouver
statistiquement ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'on à rougé affidés qui est pas ce
n'est pas très logique en termes de
stocks
et on va pas se mentir ça me fait un peu
chier se dissiperont pas figure tout
droit de droit chinois
je n'ai pas répondu
ils m'accueillent ont refilé la caméra
rouge roule à gauche non boule noire
figure
j'ai tellement honte d'avoir une mémoire
pareil je fais du droit ça te va
c'est super c'est super soutien j'ai
très mal au noir quoique ça cher en a
marre non pas du tout juste malo voir et
après je râle un bras disproportionné
par rapport à l'autre bienvenue sur la
vidéo de fabien in shape tous genres
délié du cardio les gens c'est un
plaisir aujourd'hui de vous retrouver en
plein travaux de la rue orfila c'était
je crois est alors pas si je dis pas de
bêtises ce hasard sélectif va nous faire
arriver à notre point de départ
c'est-à-dire au bar et au restaurant des
sources les sens
de quoi
quel but
de revenir sur nos pas
je sais pas mais est ce que cette vidéo
a vraiment un but
du coup je repose là et on est bien
j'avais lancé tout à l'heure mon
téléphone une application je l'arrêté
tout de suite parce qu'on peut l'arrêter
vous en pulaar étaient tous les veaux
comme entité oui toi tu as ton téléphone
à l'envers
c'était encore un piège
j'essaye de comprendre mais ce qu'il
n'ya pas content
en fait il ya un truc qui s'appelle la
ville à certains ici
koné 6 pc le hasard remarquable
la tournée quand l'équipe parce qu'ils
vous regardent que tu
tu penses à quelqu'un pour téléphone
sonne c'est cette personne là toi ça
hasard remarquable tous les jours tu
regardes ton téléphone 1 m eur
les genres d'user de safran un peu fou
coeur et je me suis dit si on s'attache
à des concepts peut-être des 50 cité
c'est la partie est
et moi je je crois qu'il n'a pas fait
voir la caméra un ton mot non d'après
toi qu'il connaît pour l'instant d'après
moi j'ai une théorie sur ce mot je pense
que ce mot tu me dis si j'ai bon ou pas
il représente une espèce de boucle à un
moment donné parce que c'est vrai ou pas
ouais je pense que c'est un concept dont
on ne verra jamais la fin je pense donc
que ça va finir
oui c'est ça et c'est drôle parce que on
a fait justement un circuit infinie et
l'application que j'ai lancé safia c'est
une application en fait qui prend nos
pas mais croissante course en fait de
deux blogueurs classique et c'est pas si
clair que ça mais je trouve quand même
que notre trajet ressemble aux limites
du symbole de la fille unique en très
gros il aurait pu être plus court le
juge peut voir quand même et on aime
bien marché et ça c'est un symbole qui
était en face de la finitude confirme ça
complètement alors sainement symbole de
l'infini
ça veut dire qu'il ya une grosse
synchronicité entre ce choix que tu as
fais toi tout seul
des décisions qui ont été prises au fur
et à mesure même quand certaines n'ont
pas arrangé du coup au final quand
ça aurait pu être du coup un autre
symbole donc en fait mon vrai travail ma
vraie difficulté c'était d'avoir
anticipé des trajets d'après moi savoir
ce que tu allais avoir pour après faire
en sorte d'essayer de manipuler un peu
le hasard ou les chanceux des stats
pourquoi on fasse un dessin rapprochant
mois mais d'accord mais comment
comment comment quoi j'aurais très bien
pu prendre l'equilibre finalement moi je
pense que je vais vous laisser là dessus
marine est un petit moment en fait
peut-être qu'on en parlera dans une
autre vidéo on parlera de des chemins de
pensée qui font qu'on prend une décision
ou pas et je reparlerai de cette vidéo à
ce moment là mais je vais j'y vais pas
vous donner de clés pour le moment je
pense à plus drôle comme ça vient après
vous pouvez avoir une autre vision
peut-être de points de vue sur la chaîne
de safia quand tu raconteras
l'expérience où tu as pris quelques
images de toute manière à les voir la
chaîne de safia ça me paraît évidente à
quoi peut-être un peu moins de 400 mille
abonnés je trouve ça scandaleux
je pense que quand vous allez découvrir
son travail ça va passer les 400000
largement de gages compte sur vous si
c'est cool je voudrais dire les
commentaires vous lis les sept semaines
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo
comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas de
liquide vous abonner et à très bientôt
ciao salée
[Musique]